Hi.
What are you playing?
Ah, the school song.
But you're playing
the soprano line.
Shouldn't you be
playing the melody?
-You're a tenor, right?
-Yeah.
Simon.
Simon, don't you know
how to read sheet music?
No, but I'm trying to learn.
But you played
so well before.
I can only play by ear, but…
you can show me.
You play.
-Sorry.
-No worries.
OK, show me.
Now you know how it goes.
Yeah.
No, no, no. Listen.
Start with these.
Those three.
Yeah! Great!
Hey…
about what happened
on Friday…
I was…
I just wanted
to say that I--
I think that maybe
we should forget about that.
Because I said that I, like…
-That I'm not like that.
-Right.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yes, I understand. I--
-You sure?
-Hey, time's up.
-Hi. I have to go.
But I still want us
to be friends.
Yeah.
My class starts soon
so I have to go.